all right welcome everyone to our third
ask me anything
I'm your host on saw kyun of simulation
where we interview leaders at the edge
of their field scientists artists
entrepreneurs educators you name it we
interview them and we are doing this AMA
because we are very excited to play some
tennis with our audience
tennis meaning the ability to hit back
and forth ideas questions and answers
and aim to stimulate each other and
hopefully aim to augment each other's
worldviews towards a more peaceful and
harmonious and scientifically driven
place so let's take a look at how many
of us have joined in already and are
asking questions I will be monitoring
the streams alright let's take a look
here
all right Luke Robert Mason what's up
brother thanks for tuning in would love
to hear a question from you and on
YouTube as well let's take a look and we
are live across both platforms YouTube
and Facebook
all right and we got some viewers across
both platforms
and we're waiting for the questions so
let's say ask Allen anything exclamation
point
let's invite some people to watch on
Facebook
maybe we'll get some questions
good to see so many familiar friends
here all right let's see what humi say
in the meanwhile tell people tune in and
ask some questions I will speak about a
couple things that have been on the mind
especially seed theory has been on my
mind that's kind of what I'm calling it
most recently the idea that every single
one of the beautiful seeds that are born
into our world humans that are born into
our world that we need the basic
nutrients air water food shelter love
compassion electricity internet
healthcare we need that in order for us
to thrive in order for us to be able to
flourish for a tree to flourish and for
us to have the fruits fruits to provide
for our families to provide for our
civilization to provide for communities
all right people that are watching ask
questions I see you guys are watching
waiting for your questions peeps
yeah last time on AMA - we had quite a
bit of fun back and forth hope to have
that again and also with that with that
seed theory there's a lot to unpack
there it has a lot to do with maximizing
our own potential and empathy towards
other people and towards what they went
through and it's important for us to
gain that sort of insight because it is
really what drives a more cohesive
planet like if you want to update the
code of the world that we live in will
then have a great deal of of drive
towards unleashing yourself fully and
helping behind the eyes of other people
that may not be unleashing themselves
fully why who got head starts well how
did they get head starts how can we
potentially help make sure that other
people can gain the same access to the
basic needs
tsommo what's up some boria what's up
thanks for joining
go ahead and ask a question if you'd
like
and I see there's three on YouTube
watching drop a question I'd love to
hear from you everyone we're monitoring
the live stream
monitoring the livestream for questions
so drop them drop them yeah sometimes I
even come in and just type a letter and
then plug a couple more people in
sometimes I do this on the streams it's
kind of interesting because people get
to see who's on the on the Fred's list
it's awesome these are people you should
follow for sure
smartypants people
one thing about interestingly enough
unscheduled AMAs are are also
interesting because people weren't
prepared to drop in and ask questions
versus if you do schedule them are
people potentially more prepared with
questions likely the answer is yes but
then people have to maybe dedicate time
slot to that specifically and that may
not be as as potentially helpful as if
it's just going live and then someone
can can tune in and ask a question
there's been a lot happening for
simulation we just hit episode number
400 which is very exciting and it's
taking us a good amount of hustle to get
there it's fun
Luke robber Mason drop a question
brother I see you just joined again good
to see him a man pump to feature you on
the show soon also on the youtubes still
got some viewers drop a question drop
question peeps
it's definitely been interesting growing
a show
of course first question from Luke
rubber mason what's the plan for an East
Coast simulation east coast of the
United States of America yes sir that is
definitely the plan it's been a little
bit difficult deciding if to just
potentially skedaddle from the Bay Area
for a year and just go interview all the
smart people possible in Cambridge in
New York and DC and stuff and we want to
do that as soon as possible but we also
understand that Silicon Valley in San
Francisco are extremely important
rumors of Boston is the next comment
from Luke Robert Mason yes that's true
it's true yeah the rumors of Boston are
true that we just came back from two
weeks of interviews in Boston
interviewed 30-plus really smart people
that those episodes will be uploaded in
the next couple of weeks and Cambridge
is very interesting Luke Cambridge is a
axis of filter for some of the smartest
people in the world Harvard and MIT and
then Tufts is there too Boston
University's their Berklee College of
musics there so it's like
northeasterners there there's so many
smart the biotech hub there is crazy
also just like Yale and Princeton and
all these other smart Dartmouth all
these other smart Ivy League's are out
there so it's a very good idea for us to
get out to the East Coast as soon as
possible and shout out to Alex Kate Chen
a Casey's a big influence of mine trying
to you know push us out there because
there's a lot of smart people out there
that he's constantly pushing us towards
via the west coast is also great you got
San Francisco and Los Angeles were close
to LA too and LA is another good good
hub but it'll be good to be able to have
people in New York also jet up to
Cambridge and the Luke I think you're
still spending most of your time in New
York now if that's right so we'll be
able to see you more often Joey thanks
for tuning in Joey chronic drop us a
question during the AMA if you
like be good to hear from you yo those
watching on YouTube as well a drop a
question still don't hear anything from
the YouTube audience Facebook excited to
hear from you
Joey drop a question to see you to
forgive these uh Luke's comments alike
yeah the East Coast will be good we'll
be able to start talking to the
prominent nodes out there more often and
interviewing them will be a lot of fun
how do you book your guests you get some
incredible folk
what's the secret do you reach out to
hundreds of folk a day Luke a great
question and I love the Foulke Foulke
that's so great yeah how to book the
guests that's great the video that we
just put on our channel called vertical
networking and hot 50 is a pretty good
resource for that basically just
identifying with people that are of
decent amount of influence on the
trajectory of our world and just wanting
to reach out to them and having kind of
like a little formula of like hey here's
two sentences it's a subject to show
invitation and two sentences is hey Luke
love your work would love to feature you
on our show let me know if you're
interested send over a date that's it
and you know hyperlinked of course to
our website and stuff so this way you
kind of just get into a flow of
constantly reaching out maybe you do ten
a day maybe do twenty a day all of a
sudden you're getting one or two replies
a day if people that want to meet with
you and I think this is really important
no matter what industry it is and no
matter if you have a media company or
not but it's still very important to be
pursuing in the media space especially
as we enter into the attention economy
that's a great it's a great question
Luke and it used to be that you know
when when your boy came out to like
Boston or it would be like probably
close to maybe like a couple dozen
emails a day on the way out to Boston or
a couple dozen emails a day on the way
out to LA or New York or wherever
because you want to be able to interview
those problems in people so you're
especially as time gets closer to you
the time that you depart and go there
that you want to you want to be able to
to reach out and in nail those guests
for the time that you're in town so
that's a great that's a great question
and Luke also host virtual futures which
I highly recommend checking out we can
give actually we can give a shout out
yeah shout out to Luke Luke robber Mason
hugely recommend virtual futures dot
Cove dot uk' check him out check out
these talks he talks are excellent
highly recommend them the salons are
super good and you know here's one of
the ones with Douglas rushkoff recently
that he did so check that out anything
on YouTube yet not on YouTube has some
questions viewers on YouTube
it's interesting thinking about it from
the perspective of how long that it
it takes to get the decent amount of
people that are tuning in and viewing
when you do it live without a scheduled
time versus doing it with a scheduled
time because that's maybe something that
we explore doing in the future
there's doing the scheduled scheduled
AMA
because obviously 14 minutes and I want
to be a value to you guys you know
that's the thing about unscheduled a
amazes that I want to make sure that I'm
a value and that you know these pieces
of content need to be valuable let's get
back to the tube
comment your questions
all right another question from Luke
Robert Mason Preston Curley what's up
brother drop a question Preston would
love to hear from you my man Luke robber
Mason's the most recent question how do
you find time to research folk do you
use a default set of questions as
fallback takes me over a week to read
their latest book and do background
reading - you managed to do almost one a
day sometimes incredible thank you thank
you my man thank you and it's a great
question I would say that with applying
whatever is the Pareto principle to the
people that were talking to are really
important as in just really trying to
find the the 20% of information about
them that's gonna give you 80% of the
knowledge about who they are and what
they stand for because sometimes it
doesn't take a week to get that
information so I mean I'm really as long
as someone who's like interviewing me is
still like oh like you have a show
called simulation and you featured 400
plus people and you do it it's
multidisciplinary you feature different
leaders I'd be like yeah that's pretty
damn good that's like that's probably
like whatever a vast majority of what I
am what I represent and what not so so
that's that's some food for thought I
know what you I know how you feel though
like you want to read their whole book
you want to read their whole Wikipedia
and all the links and all the articles
and all the interviews video interviews
that they've done and all that kind of
stuff but really what are their core
thesis points and actually another point
Luke that you know may be helpful is
that coming up with the questions one of
the most important things as an
interlocutor is just to know how to when
when we ask and I'm such I'm still in
kindergarten but I'm learning as best as
I can right now is that asking pressing
questions that are open-ended that get
them to think like we like starting
shows by asking what people's thoughts
are on the direction of our world then
people get a nice little view into their
world view then asking people about
their journey like tell us about your
journey how you got here right boom
that's the end of the question and they
just
shut up and let them talk and then if
they say oh I got interested in art or
science or blah blah from whatever thing
then we ask a follow-up like oh that's
so cool so tell us about that mentor
that ensured you two neuroscience that
got you interested in it and then they
unpack it more but then when you get
into the meet the heavier stuff like if
they're in like if they're in like you
know like if they're in clean meat or if
they're in let's check what youtube
quick okay nothing on the youtubes you
know homies on YouTube give us a comment
give us a comment I see you guys
watching so if they're in like clean
meat or whatever industry they're in you
know ask the questions that that get
that get people that get you into the
depth like okay how does clean meat work
teach us about that that cell
replication that needs to happen and how
to actually get it to the bioreactors
and get it to feeding billions of people
as soon as possible
right what are the challenges that are
holding back clean meat right now what
are what what would it be like huh what
would it be like for our for the massive
agriculture and factory farming that we
do with animals and how much of the of
the are we what would it what would it
do to the pollution effects on the
planet what would it do to our
spirituality to not be slaughtering
these animals and so so it's kind of
like you know digging into the most
pressing themes on the subject of clean
meat or whatever the subject is we're
discussing with the leader that we're
sitting down with so that's typically
where I head and then I do really like
having a set of questions at the end I
like asking people what the most
beautiful thing in the world is I think
that's an interesting question to ask
people I think if you really want to
press a bit I like asking people if they
think that there is a global ruling
elite I think that's an interesting
question to ask another interesting one
is if they think we're alone in the
cosmos if they think we're in a
simulation what they believe to be true
that almost nobody else believes to be
true questions like that are very cool
and so having kind of like a set of
questions at the end that you think are
pretty good also Luke something else
that could be really beneficial to you
as having a testimonial at the end so
having them spend like just 36
seconds of explaining why people should
watch virtual futures and also giving
you the recommendations you know three
or four referrals to other prominent
speakers that you should feature on
virtual futures so see ya so I hope
that's I hope that that's a pretty
decent blurb so I try and I really try
and apply the pareto to people's
backgrounds so I can get the the the key
points and I also like to co-create with
them quite a bit so when they arrived I
showed them what I have and then I asked
for them to co-create with me what they
want to talk about because I don't want
to talk about things they don't want to
talk about and I also want them to tell
me what they do they want to talk about
just in case if I've missed things as
well so we definitely co-create part of
the outline together as well and there
have been some you know pictures on the
interwebs of me doing the outlines on
the whiteboard I used to do them on the
whiteboard and then I realized how much
yo youtubers drop us the questions some
questions in the live chat youtubers in
terms of Luke in terms of where I used
to take notes I used to take a lot of
notes on the whiteboard and then I
realized how just whiteboard is a medium
that is is just it's slow it's further
away from me I can't you know edit it as
easily and it's not obviously not
digitally saved afterwards so what I
decided to do is just put the notes on
my laptop I think that's a great idea
you know just have like both their bio
the show episode name the links in the
bio as well as the the couple points
that you've put into this co-created
outline and then just have that in front
of you on the computer and you're not
referencing it every single time you
need to make a point but occasionally
you reference it and it's also nice to
have the visuals up there on the
computer so if you want to reference the
visuals in the conversation you can do
so quite easily and just reference the
the visual if they're talking about the
autonomous car and all of the sensors on
the car and how it processes the data
then maybe you want to actually
bring up that asset of the autonomous
vehicle and all the sensors on it so
that people can gain a better
understanding visually of what they're
talking about as well
got some shy guys on on on youtubes
peeps watchin but not dropping Hughes
another one of the things that that is
actually like quite interesting about
all of this is that I feel like I feel
like most people go go into what they
pursue doing not knowing about what they
are getting themselves into like I
definitely didn't know what I was
getting myself into people like to say
like oh yeah I totally knew I knew I
knew this whole time that I was what
exactly what I was getting myself into
people people who people rarely know
like when people start the massive
companies of the world they rarely think
that they were gonna end up doing that
so it's very funny just as you're slowly
growing something you also realize how
much time that you have to spend doing
it like I spent so much time on this
project right you were just talking
about the bit little bit ago Luke so it
can sometimes be Joey hit us up with the
question Joey chronics you in there
yo youtubers drop a question I see you
guys watch and drop a question
yeah it's like just so much time that we
spend
we spend a lot of time on building what
we what we're working on into the world
and we spend less time on doing all the
social things that so many other people
are doing I think that's one of the most
interesting parts of entrepreneurship is
the sacrifice the sacrifice that people
make in order to pursue entrepreneurship
it's justified from the back again just
funny I always wondered what actually
happens when you hit on their names like
how when they get the notification and
what it says and stuff
[Music]
oh it's such a beautiful place mother
earth is such a beautiful place
Oh as I wait for these next couple
questions I will sing a song and hope
that everyone gets so long let's try
love let's try peace let's try bliss
let's get there together one person at a
time
hold and hand and hand we can do it if
we try we can we can there is science
and art there is a and Wonder we can do
it together find the mix in between get
inspired and inspire others to build
because what better way is there to be
than in peace and harmony peace and
harmony turret turret turret you'll drop
us some questions on that youtubes we
see all your folk watching on that
youtubes
am a ask me anything on YouTube on
Facebook people drop the questions
yeah do you just want to make sure this
is great value for people and like
something like it does seem like it's
probably better to schedule these cuz
it's like almost half an hour in and I
basically had one conversation Griffin
what's up brother thanks for tuning into
the Facebook live stream would love to
hear a question from you it's an AMA ask
me anything so drop a question any
question my man hope you've been well
hope you've been well
[Music]
can be about anything anything anything
at all anything at all it can be about
time it can be about space it can be
about the human brain or it can be about
the human race it can be about all the
species on the planet or the species on
Titan because soon we'll know once we
send astronauts up there
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do healthy emojis is so
funny you know Robert I see you I see
you sending emojis on Facebook or drop a
question my man would love to hear from
you drop some questions in the AMA same
thing on the youtubes people peeps be
watching but there's a need those who
need those questions this is an AMA need
the questions
bump bump bump bump bump bump bump bump
bump bump bump bump bump bump bump
that's a heartbeat bump bump bump bump
Cosmo what's up brother good to see you
thanks for tuning in to the AMA Cosmo
would love to hear a question from you
also stay strong my brother I love you
very very much
stay strong stay healthy stay smart keep
doing you we need you I love you
hey Cosmo when I see her comment talking
to you my man talking to you soon uh
I'll be able to loop people in via like
Skype or via messenger directly into the
conversation
oh yeah that's a good one yeah it's
exactly what's happening right now
that's so funny
do me a favor and ask Alan a question
ask him to ask Alan to ask Alan I just
love infinite recursive you so many of
us as a million point to them wait
that's the wrong way this way
who is this guy who is this guy
that's funny that's funny the infinite
recruit a scout and to ask Alan to ask
Alan that's good stuff that's good stuff
all right YouTube's you got a question
for me Oh YouTube's yo what's up
youtubes I didn't know that people were
commenting what's up guys thanks for
tuning in all right how did simulation
TV start also what's your educational
background if that's relevant all right
dirty kicks what's up on YouTube thanks
for tuning in dirty kicks all right so
let's hit um let's hit that up real
quick so the question from dirty kicks
is how did simulation TV start well
simulation started with a fascination
for insatiable curiosity and it also
started with questions lots and lots of
questions the most thought-provoking
questions we're trying to really ask
leaders that around us
questions about the ethical evolution of
our civilization how we can maximize our
potential how we were going to handle
ourselves in exponential technology HR
we're gonna handle eachother
geopolitically what we're gonna do about
genetic engineering and neural
prosthetics and artificial general
intelligence so they started with the
questions with the deepest emotions
we've ever felt if we think we're in a
simulation if we think that we're alone
in the cosmos and so what happens
outside of the 3d reality that we live
in so it happened you came from the
fascination with the questions and
that's a good question thanks for
kicking us off with that and then of
course it was just inviting them to come
on to the show and to answer the
questions that we had for them and talk
about their journeys and inspire and
engage other people to build the future
what's your educational background if
that's relevant okay
educational background I mostly science
communication mostly entrepreneurship
are the two big ones other major
influences on me were debate when I was
younger another major influence was
soccer so your teamwork a lot of
teamwork was a big one also a lot of a
lot of just oh I'm like my mother love
and compassion from my mom was a big one
huge one and very grateful for my uncle
as well and all he's done for for
raising me and Ron Vegas who's usually
sits here was the producer director of
the show all right let's get to the
other questions good questions good
questions and just one more blast
the educational background is that
number one things insatiable curiosity
man if you got the insatiable curiosity
if you have the energy to ask a lot of
questions you're gonna go far but just
you've got to keep doing that okay how
come they don't make any funny movies
from leigh.m like something about Mary
anymore
also from Liam if you are going to
commit suicide due to automation how
would you do it oh man what a question I
don't know about the movie the funny
movies they make some funny movies don't
they really it's time for knowledge it's
time for you know movies to have really
strong bits of knowledge in them for
people to become more enlightened with
because so much of Hollywood is just
it's just in so much of Silicon Valley
as well lots of parts of our world are
just filled with noise
that's funny question if you're going to
it's just I'd do to automation how would
you do it um I don't know this is so
many interesting options I'm going to
like the Mariana Trench in a submarine
and then like or shooting myself out of
the submarine and then having the water
pressure just crush the body or like
jumping out of an airplane without a
parachute or doing some kind of a
demonstration about like peace and unity
before death like I don't know like
laying in the middle of Market Street in
San Francisco and just like laying there
in the middle of Market Street with like
a bunch of signs that say like peace and
love and unity and respect and like
change the world update civilizations
code get away from the greed and the
corruption that's corrupting our souls
and then like you know you know go away
that way it's interesting questions very
dark questions interesting stuff I'm not
I'm nothing fearless I'll answer your
questions for sure for sure hopefully
can keep updating code for a while
though before that okay let's check back
to the to the Facebook's okay some more
questions I can't post a screenshot but
I'm glad you notice now that's funny
yeah of course I noticed cause well it's
a Michael Lynn what's up Michael thanks
for tuning in would love to hear from
you Genesis what's up would love to hear
from you Joseph would love to hear from
you
chohee hit with some man good to see you
we're getting into flame wars with
Republicans ever be automated that's a
tough one um flame wars with Republicans
ever be automated well hopefully we can
find that peace in unity and love and
respect rather than that war let's get
there that's super important some more
questions from the YouTube a message was
retracted before I could read it more in
fizz back why'd you retract your message
ask questions
with us
Felix what's up good to see you my man
Felix drop us a question it's been a
while love to hear from you you may ask
me anything the recursive sake Ahn's hey
Felix thanks for the comment to see you
my man let me know if you have any
questions
it's an AMA you can ask me anything
thanks Cosmo one hundo P gotta gotta we
got to love the shirts comment 100% got
a stick out you know gotta represent
what we believe in with the clothing
that we wear question from Felix who was
going to win uber or Tesla that's a good
question
it's a great question good question
Felix alright who's gonna win uber or
Tesla hmm well uber could win if they
put in a shitload of their time and
resources into figuring out how to win
on the autonomous front but Tesla
apparently has the most miles driven and
the greatest slurping of data from the
roads uber has a lot of interesting data
though about people's behaviors in terms
of how when they ride how often they
ride all that stuff it'll be interesting
to see them both put into competition
and see what happens next question from
Felix when we finally get Fusion Energi
& Kosmos reply was when Tesla invents it
that's funny I agree though Fusion
Energi is massively important you can
see right there the question in the
reply Fusion Energi is critical we need
that as soon as possible
and there is a bunch of people working
on it and this isn't just the IT
over on Europe that's doing it but now
it's even smaller and smaller nuclear
fusion reactors and potentially our
ability to you know to put get out more
energy than we put in and just do that
over and over again I mean that's that's
game over as soon as we can get there
just look at the Sun for for inspiration
is such a beautiful fusion reactor
that's giving providing all life in the
solar system okay some more questions
how difficult is it to get guests I
would like to host my own podcast with
comedy and interesting guests from dirty
kicks yo dirty kicks good question how
difficult is it to get guess it's if you
watch the episode that we just did on
vertical networking and hot 50 it's a
very short eight minutes episode we
actually break down how to maximize
speed and efficiency with identifying
people that you want to feature on the
show and then just booking them and
providing them with value and going
through that process very short messages
highly recommend checking that out
another comment from dirty cakes even
though your channel isn't huge yet you
have very interesting guests thank you
thank you do you think AI will slow down
no I don't think AI will slow down what
are some rarely spoken areas in computer
science that are important that we don't
commonly hear about oh that's a good
question
oh oh yeah nice aw dirty kicks saw the
vertical networking show was good glad
you saw it during kicks also dirty kicks
one more thought for you quick before I
answer your dirty kicks start that
podcast up ma man really get it going
this is the time right now get it while
it's good the attention economy is still
in its process of flourishing so you can
you got to pump out lots of content that
content library it built that content
catalog built but go and get it done get
it done and it's hard to do because it
you know requires you to wake up every
morning and build instead of wake up
every morning and just go to Netflix or
just go to get a beer with a friend but
no you got to stay home and work and get
build your product projects and stuff
but it brings more meaning to life for
those that are willing to explore it and
have good conversations that that that
build important things into our world
bring in Tai Lopez or James Marshall
yeah I don't um I don't know who James
Marshall is I know Tai Lopez is James
Marshall who is that
oh this is someone that's passed it
might be another one James Marshall
actor known for playing the character
James Hurley okay cool cool if that's
him yeah I'm very down with guest
recommendations so if anyone's connected
just shoot an email simulation series at
gmail.com make the introduction will
happily take over and just dirty kicks
to answer your quick previous question
about what are some rarely spoken areas
and computer science that are important
that we don't commonly hear about you
know what's very interesting about that
question is that your boy actually needs
to learn that subject a lot better I
need to learn more about computer
science and about the subject areas in
that field that are doing really
interesting things one of the things
that we are that we're probably most
familiar with now is neural networks and
the prepare process of being able to do
things like identify images oh I won
what is this this is a dog oh what is
this is a car and that's very
interesting in the process by how neural
networks actually make those identifying
decisions but then there's a lot of
other complicated things like if you
were to try and and make anything that's
not a narrow intelligence and narrow
intelligence like playing chess or
playing go or playing Starcraft even
Starcraft's getting more complicated but
still in narrow intelligence because
it's not like start that alpha alpha
alpha star can't go and get you a glass
of orange juice from the fridge so you
know there's so anyway the advancements
generative adversarial networks are kind
of interesting they're also a little bit
scary because I feel like deep fakes
have a lot of potential for causing a
lot of mayhem on the planet and so that
would be another question or another
area that it's kind of crazy that is
important to to dive into also other
areas in computer science are just new
programming languages I mean everyone
talks about Python I think that's very
interesting I think JavaScript also just
also just knowing how to put together
and break apart computers know how to
write lines of code know how to make
code modular making new LAN make new
code it'll be interesting to see
artificial intelligence writing code
for intelligence writing code and what a
coding language looks like that it makes
these are good questions from dirty
kicks thanks for giving us the questions
I'll give you a things
thanks dirty kicks
good questions boom alright back to de
Chi Joshua fields what's up guys would
love to your questions from you if you
guys are interested would love to hear
questions from you or I'm about to wrap
this up in a bit we got some questions
yeah thanks dirty kicks much appreciated
GWT one two three ask solar activity or
co2 which one has the greater impact to
climate change
interesting solar activity or co2 okay
as in maybe that means co2 emissions and
their effects on climate change or solar
Oh solar activity as an alec solar
energy that we do but solar activity oh
like from the Sun yeah yeah yeah like
like all of the solar flares and stuff
like that there's a lot here's what's
interesting here's one thing that I will
say that's very contrarian and anyone
can clip this out as they please but I
think anyone that's running around just
screaming about the consensus on on on
on just in general about global warming
and whatnot I think what's more
important to do than screaming about the
consensus cuz that's not getting to any
one heart soul emotion intellect energy
at all is to actually break down the
variables tell a good story and break
down the variables be like okay we know
very little about solar flares they do
this type of stuff to the planet the
earth orbits a star this amount of time
it's this close this far away Jupiter
and Saturn their relationship on the
earth and how it gets dragged outer or
closer to the star I mean there's so
many things that actually go into the
process of the earth being heated by the
star that we're just so ignorant of so
it's so funny when one little brain
inside of one of these vehicles will
runs around and says oh my god this or
oh my god that like yeah it's true like
some parts per million of co2 increase
in our atmosphere some of our ocean
acidification is happening right these
are very important things to identify
but we can potentially do things like
genetically engineer phytoplankton in
the ocean
to sequester more co2 but we also need
to transition a nuclear fusion we need
transition to solar energy when you
transition to other forms of energy as
well as quickly as possible because we
need a sustainable civilization for a
long period of time so it's a great
question thanks for that question GWT
one two three all right I'm a wrap this
Q&A it's been 45 minutes good job
everyone really appreciate you tuning in
you shout out to our audience on
youtubes if you'd shout out to our
audience on the Facebook's thank you
very much for tuning in everyone greatly
appreciate it much love much love to you
both platforms and that's it everyone
thanks for tuning in to the say ma it's
good to have done the third one we'll
keep doing AMAs as we go overtime
gonna take a quick sip of tea mmm good
stuff we'll figure out if we want to
schedule these or if we want to keep
them on the fly but come with questions
as always come with questions and go ask
your friends and your co-workers and
social media in your families ask
questions ask questions ask questions
ask people things have that insatiable
curiosity go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world and that's it thanks for tuning in
to this AMA and we will see you soon
peace